-Our next guest is a very funny
actress you know from shows
such as "Cougar Town"
and "Freaks and Geeks."
She stars in the second season
of "Girls5eva,"
which is streaming now
on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-Kev.
I'm going on a tour.
You're gonna stay with Stevia.
-No, I'm not to be trusted!
-You'll figure it out.
Just like I had to
when you went to Tampa.
-Ugh!
-Hey!
Listen to me.
Be her best friend,
not her parent.
Win her heart
through possessions.
And find out what she's up to by
posing as an older, very cool,
CGI shapewear CEO on TikTok.
I'll give you the account
and the password I made up.
Also --
-Can I get paper?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Busy Philipps,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show, Busy.
-Hi!
-I'm so happy to have you back.
-Oh, my God, I'm so happy
to be here.
-And you're a New Yorker
this time.
-This is it, Seth.
I live in New York.
-You live in New York City now.
-I do!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We last talked via Zoom
in 2020,
and you were still
a Los Angelino.
-Here's what I'm gonna say.
-Yeah.
-None of this was
on my bingo card.
-Okay.
-If you had paid anyone that
knows me millions of dollars to
say, "Will Busy ever live
in New York," they would say no.
-Yeah.
-And they would lose the bet,
but here we are.
Because Tina Fey called me
and said,
"Do you want to do
this TV show?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, obviously."
-And then you --
I mean, you could have gone back
in between seasons.
You dug it!
Admit you dig it.
-Here's what I'm gonna say.
We have teens now,
like preteen teenagers.
-Yeah.
-And I really feel like New York
offers a thing
that Los Angeles doesn't,
which isn't to say that L.A.
doesn't have culture, but...
[ Laughter ]
...it's just
a different culture.
Do you know what I mean?
-I think the thing about
New York culture is if you just
walk down the street, you're
gonna get a fair share of it.
-You get it.
I've gotten it in my face.
-Yep.
-I've gotten it on my shoes.
I kicked a rat once, I mean.
-You did?
Did you apologize?
-Oh, always.
I'm like, "Sir, sir,
I'm so sorry, sir."
-Because the rats in your
neighborhood know
the other rats, and then if you
get a bad reputation --
-Yeah.
-Now, your kids,
Birdie and Cricket.
-Yes.
-So, they are enjoying it?
-Yeah, they love it.
-Okay. They don't miss L.A.?
-No, they actually,
like, don't miss L.A.
-That's really nice.
-Yeah, it is nice.
-I've asked about this. Have you
introduced them to past work?
I mean, do they watch
"Girls5eva"?
-Yeah. Well, no. Well, okay.
So, you guys know -- I mean,
I've been an actor since I was
like a kid, basically.
I was 19 years old when I did
"Freaks and Geeks."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am about to turn 43!
And that's true.
That's true,
I'm about to turn 43.
Do you find that, like -- I just
almost said 41 because I turned
40 right before the pandemic,
and in my head I just was like,
"I'm about to turn 41."
And you wouldn't have known,
and I could have just done it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway.
-They should have passed a law
that none of the birthdays
during the pandemic counted.
-I don't think they did!
-Yeah.
-I mean, they didn't count.
-Everybody's like,
"Forgive student loans."
Forgive my two birthdays!
[ Laughter ]
-Seth!
Forgive my two birthdays.
So, I'm about to turn 41,
I've been acting since I was 19,
and I have these two kids.
And I've been trying --
My kids love TV.
They love shows.
And Birdie, especially
if you have a teenager,
you know this -- like, they love
to watch old shows.
And I'm like,
"Guess what I'm on."
[ Laughter ]
I'm on "Dawson's Creek"
and "Freaks and Geeks."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not interested.
-No, really?
-No, no.
-Because they don't
like the show
or because they don't want to
see you?
-It's me.
-Okay.
-100% it's me.
I tried to show Cricket,
who's our almost 9-year-old,
"Girls5eva."
She watched it for two seconds.
You guys just saw the clip.
I hope you're watching the show
because it's really funny.
And she said, "Your voice is
really weird on this.
I don't like it at all."
And I was like, "Okay."
But so anyways, so Birdie's been
like, emphatically no.
Has watched -- The last time we
talked, it was Birdie's birthday
in the pandemic, and I got all
my friends who are on
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine" to, like,
do a little video
for Birdie at home.
That's because I've been in TV
since I was a child.
I know everyone.
-That's very nice.
-Anyway.
And like, yeah, so she's watched
"The Office,"
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
"Parks and Rec."
She loves you.
She loves everyone except for,
like, hasn't watched anything
I'm on.
[ Laughter ]
And I've tried,
and she won't do it,
and then last night --
they won't do it.
Last night,
Birdie had a friend over.
And I invited them to come down
for dinner, and they did
and of course sat
in front of the TV.
And I was, like, preparing
things in the kitchen
and then I heard the theme
from "Freaks and Geeks."
-Wow.
[ Audience oohs ]
-And I was like,
"Is it happening?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Be cool, be cool."
"What are you guys watching?!"
[ Laughter ]
And Birdie was like,
"Bevan wanted to see you on TV,
so we turned on
'Freaks and Geeks.'"
And I was like,
"That's cool, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
"And it was so weird.
That's me. I was 19, g--"
And Birdie goes --
and I'm not kidding you --
"You talk really weird
on this show."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Okay."
And so anyway, they watched it,
and then at a certain point,
the girl came to do my nails
for your show.
And I was like, "Okay, I got to
go get my nails done."
And Birdie just took
the controller
and was like,
"We've seen enough."
[ Laughter ]
-You got to wait for you
to leave.
You were leaving the room
anyway!
Wait for you to leave.
-It was the point!
You know, the cruelty
is the point!
-Oh, yes!
I hope -- Well, you know,
hopefully she's gonna look past
the fact that she hates seeing
you on TV to watch me tonight
and will hear that you're being
very mean to your mother.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you know, one of --
We talked about culture,
but obviously Broadway.
And I'm wondering if Birdie
or Cricket likes going to
Broadway shows
and if you take them.
-Well, I would, but again,
it's been a pandemic.
And so, and I've been on
a TV show
and I don't want to get people
sick with COVID.
-Right, of course.
-But I did -- Like, things are
opening back up
and we actually got COVID,
so now I feel a little bit
better about it.
And you know that feel--
I mean, you all know
that feeling, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the right after
is pretty not bad.
-Well, that's what it --
that's where we're at.
-Oh, you're the right after.
Oh, my God, live your best life,
yeah.
-So, I've been wanting to see
"A Strange Loop,"
which is this amazing show
that just won a Tony.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-And I knew nothing about it,
but I was like,
"Just got to see the show,"
and so I bought tickets
and I'm like, "Birdie, we're
going to the show
on Saturday night,"
and I saw on Instagram
that Sara Bareilles,
who's on "Girls5eva" with me
and also is just a big star
in her own right,
and I just follow her on
Instagram for that reason,
was at the show, and so I texted
her, "Oh, I'm so excited.
I'm taking Birdie tonight."
And Sara wrote back,
"Dot, dot, dot."
And I was like,
"What's that mean?"
And Sara was like, "Do you know
what it's about, babe?
It's, like, pretty mature."
And I was like,
"Well, Birdie's like a teenager.
It's going to be fine."
And then Sara calls me
and she's like,
"Uh, no, Busy. Um...
Like, in the show, in the first
song, they say there's going to
be butt[bleep] onstage."
[ Audience ohhs ]
[ Laughter ]
They deliver!
-They don't over-promise.
-They don't disappoint!
And I was like, "Oh.
Oh, no. Well, what do I do?"
Well, Birdie watches
"Bridgerton," but not with me.
[ Laughter ]
So I had this whole dilemma.
And so then I was like,
you know what?
Communication is key.
I'm like, "Birdie, the show that
I'm really excited
to take you to,
this is the situation.
Sara Bareilles told me
that this happens onstage,"
and Birdie's like,
"Yeah, no, we're good.
I'm not going to go
to that with you."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That was it?
-And that was it.
And then I took my friend,
and it was great.
-That's great.
-And it's an amazing show.
-Alright. That's great.
But maybe not for new teenagers.
-Well, I would just say that
like we don't watch "Bridgerton"
sitting next to each other.
Do you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-No child, no matter how, like,
evolved and communicative
you are with your teenagers,
wants to watch sex
with your mom,
even if your mom is me
and you're so cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if there's any message
to take away, let it be that.
That's parenting advice
from Busy Philipps, everybody!
"Girls5eva" is available now
on Peacock.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."